[Music]  speaking of co-parenting app seems to be  what Janet Jackson is trying to do with  her ex well at least for the holidays et  has learned that Janet plans to return  to the UK with their 11 month old son so  he can be reunited with his father but  tonight Janet is on stage there's four  more shows left before her tour wraps  Sunday in Atlanta after that the two  will return to London so they can spend  ESA's first Christmas with Janet  soon-to-be-ex-husband Wisam Amana as for  the state of the divorce everything  civil right now but a source close to  Janet tells us don't rule out a quote  very contentious custody battle the  couple will be using a mediator for the  time being  the billionaire allowed her to take  their son on tour and now he wants his  son back home for the holidays and made  longer the concert is so good if you  have a chance go see her there for more  stops left  [Music]  you